I used to play a filmmaking Would You
Rather game all the time haven't played
it in a while and your movie gives me an
excuse to bring it back so that is where
we're starting I love it let's do it so
I'll give you would you rather question
and I want to know your answer and also
why you would choose one or the other so
I'll go with a with an acting specific
one first here would you rather have to
do a hundred takes or only get one take
in a scene one take one take yes any day
yeah I would definitely not 100 a
hundred takes I become a robot after the
third one I my mouth starts moving in a
horrible to reduce the sense right and
use magic yeah one take is a lot of
pressure yes especially like actiony
stuff definitely a lot of pressure but I
would rather deal with the pressure
because I come in strong anyway I'm
prepped when I come in
um and my my first few takes are my best
usually so I oh my gosh one take place
100 oh my God
very understandable there I'll I'll do a
I'll do a fun one now what would you
rather play the killer in a horror movie
or would you rather get a really gnarly
death scene
um I'd rather be the Killer
well if I had a mask on I would rather
get a gnarly death no but then you get
when you get to reveal the mask yeah but
then you're filming for one day you know
stunt double or somebody does the rest
of it oh really yeah you mean you don't
get do you think the guy you think
you're getting the guy and scream like
short for 100 days oh my God you tell me
it could be the same person it could be
literally anyone it could have been you
it could have been me no but the whole
point in a Scream movie is that you're
walking around in the flesh and you're
trying to you know get your group of
friends to not think you're the killers
yeah you suspect well maybe if it was
green then yes but um anything else I
think I that's a hard one man that's
tough how have you died a lot I have
I've had a few debts have you yeah a few
yeah yeah yeah oh well now I need to
know can you each tell me your favorite
death scene that you've ever filmed I
received I died
um
oh mine was one was I had a dramatic one
what was that I had a dramatic one I was
killed in this movie Hindi movie called
agneepath
right after I get married oh God so um
he's a he's like a gangster and his the
villains come and they're having a
shootout but I get shot and I'm dressed
as a bride and I have a melodramatic
death
um did you come back to life or is that
it no I literally died so yeah the
movie's over for you yeah it wasn't a
franchise
yeah I'm trying to think of mine I can't
think about I mean I've been doing
Outlander for 10 years so uh he's still
alive I can't come close to death a lot
but uh tell us a close to death but I
did something many years ago where yeah
I was hung uh it was kind of cool yeah
so how do you get that like wait I've
never been hung how do you get that like
oh yeah you practice at home with this
like God do not but F disclaimer do not
practice practice don't say such things
we're promoting a rom-com what is
happening
what if you're the scream now I know
that you're the screen killer
you both need to be in either a Scream
movie or I'll throw out a final
destination movie they're making another
one and you get really cool death scenes
in those yeah yeah yeah
would you rather question next would you
rather have to fake vomit in a scene or
fake sneeze in a scene them both fake
sneeze is easier yeah do you know find
fake vomiting actually sometimes give
you like soup or something you're gonna
throw up in water it kind of makes you
want to throw up a bit yeah that's what
I'm saying keeping it in your mouth is
really disgusting yeah rather fake
sneeze because I can but do that really
well that's good
um that is a good one thank you but like
I think you had to in the movie didn't
you I don't know I remember
but vomit's like gross because it gets
cold in your mouth by the camp by the
time or like it's like staying in your
mouth by the time the camera rolls and
it's just not feeling a bit nauseous now
sorry oh no good thing we're ending this
game I am moving on to a regular
question and so I always love asking
about uh the value of having a good
scene partner and it seems especially
important when you're making a romantic
comedy like this so can you each tell me
about a time when the other was just the
scene partner you needed and helped you
crush a challenging scene or maybe
access something in your character that
you wouldn't have been able to reach
without them
um I think that for me
um
Sam is just extremely gracious and just
he's someone who you know I ask a lot of
questions
um and I know this about myself and I
ask a lot of questions I have a lot of
like conversations when I'm doing a
scene and he's just so wonderfully
adaptive and gives me the
um
even if I have a stupid idea
will never make me feel that way while
we're working together you know he's
like so do you have any bad ideas but
he's just so good with bringing people
together he he really like when he's on
set it's always joyous and positive and
that's so important to not have like a
toxic environment
um and I've had many of those as well
his positivity stop now okay you're so
bad at taking compliments
listen Priyanka now he has to give it
back no it does it can't turns up and
she's so strong it's so caring for
everyone on set and uh you know that's
the most important part of this movie is
that we have this great chemistry and
connection and
um and I think you know I think Priyanka
was there in every scene giving you know
as good as she gets and she's just such
a joy to work with so
um
oh that's why we have chemistry because
we like each other
now I want you to give yourselves
compliments this is my new favorite
overly sentimental question to ask
because in this industry we give Awards
out to each other and that is wonderful
but I feel like no one says good job to
themselves nearly enough so is there any
particular scene whether it's in this
movie or anything you've done that you
can look back on and say to yourself
damn I am proud of what I did there for
me
yeah I'm straight in there uh so go
watch our movie
um it's out this week uh stay till the
end the end credits oh yes the end
credits and I'm telling you yes that's
so but you were so good in that too yeah
but I had to reshoot mine you did yours
one take artist
um but yeah I think that's a good one
you guys that's a surprise at the end of
the movie Sam yours is a specially well
shot too who filmed that for you very
much yeah did it all on my own back you
know
um what I'm just giving it I'm giving it
I'm not giving anything away here yeah
let's not tell everyone but this was
like shot by professional drone or
something whatever suck
[Music]
before before they kicked me out I'll
squeeze in one more question here what
is a uh a new tool in your acting tool
kit so to speak that you know you gained
from from this movie that you are eager
to apply to a future movie that you do
for sure
um I cut bangs for this movie because
um my right sorry but my character was
like a sad writer and I felt like
sad writers I don't know
she needed bangs yeah
sound writer these oh no oh
I know oh you're not a sad writer at all
and you're happy and you're joyous if
you have bangs I was clearly mistaken
but I loved my bangs so
um that's something I don't know if it's
in my acting toolkit or not but growing
Banks I want to see if I want to cut my
bangs and bring back the banks and now
we've I'm inspired sad bangs no I'm
inspired looking at your bangs
I love that you just insulted all our
journalists but I played it I played a
journalist I should have wanted it again
there's my insult there literally was
saying that that I wanted bangs again
and I added that to my actor
I'll tell you this interview went to
Corners that I never would have expected
between the bank conversation and the
horror movie conversation we've covered
everything there's nothing left for me
right now I will say congratulations and
thank you for your time thank you so
much